[موسيقى]
بدي اعمله الان حضرتك على التلفزيون
اللي بنشوفه على فيسبوك وعلى وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي
ان هو يقلص
الصحافه الورقيه او ان هو يعني يذهب بها
الى غياب النسيان كمطبعات ورقيه
[موسيقى]
كانت الصحافه ضرورها قدريه مساله قدريه لا
خيال امامك الا انك تقرا صحيفه تنتظر اذا
سمحت تنتظر حالا ما يعني ظهرت التواصل هل
الوسائط الاجتماعيه المختلفه والتقنيات
المختلفه
كانت كثير مؤسسات الاعلاميه العربيه وليس
فقط سعوديا مترهله او مطمئنه فلم تستطع
التفاعل بشكل ايجابي او شكل سريع ديناميكي
مثل ما حدث في مؤسسات غربيه
عصر الصحيفه الممسوكه باليد والقراءه لم
يبقى منه غير الف يا قارئ هنا وهناك في كل
صحيفه بعد ما كان العدد الاسبوعي مثلا
يوزع مليون نسخه من الاهرام وزيه مثلا من
الوفد المصريه يا مصطفى